and it is cortez
who that blue jay starting lineup is
going to face
so a big game for him a big game for the
yankees is they have to stop this losing
streak and get back to their winning
ways
so bobachet will get the lead off here
for cortez looking for his first hit on
the road trip
there's a drive to left field get out of
here and gamble this has jump-started
the offense once again
that's the 19th home run the blue jays
have hit a jackie stadium this season
they've out homer to the yanks 19-5
and maybe again a little different look
leading off of a ball game instead of
hitting fourth maybe a little bit higher
gives him a different look and maybe
it'll work out cortez has had a lot of
success this year against right-handed
batters
28th start of the season for jose
mourinho she can't pitch much better
than he has his last couple of starts he
takes his 10-7-3 55 earned run average
into this
game and they go right back to that same
spot and get a pop-up vladi is there and
that'll do it
nice job by jose maria i'm like how's
this guy hitting 217.
this guy is a
bit tough on the chase
well right there he got full badly on a
curve ball from barrios and waved at the
ball that bounced on home plate
quick feet quick move to first
there's a base hit to right field for
judge a lot of room on that right side
rochelle will stop at second
well if you're in judge this is an
option every single time somebody is on
first base with that huge hole on the
right side
he jammed him right there beau comes
after it makes the play and that'll do
it the yankees get a couple of singles
but they strand a pair barrios makes
another good pitch on anthony rizzo
only has one strikeout that was a brett
gardner in the third
another change up that's a fair ball
that's going to go all the way to the
wall
and stanton is around first he better
hurry up the close play and he's safe
boy stan just looked like he was jogging
around first and guerrillas got a
terrific arm and he made it close at
second
throw beat him by a mile also and and
marcus had some time to to drop that
glove down
let's see he's there
oh it sure looked like he he got him on
that knee i hope they show that one
replay he tagged him on the leg before
that hand tagged the bag so we'll see
absolutely
good job by the replay and guerrilla
celebrates another outfit assist his
12th of the season randall zoe for one
he flied to right his first time up
3-2 pitch to grinchik is hit high in the
air out to deep left field gallow turns
and watches it go
randall grinchik unloads his 22nd of the
season
deep into the seats in left field
and it's two nothing blue jays
the second solo home run of the night
for
toronto it's their 20th home run at
yankee stadium this season
and it's two nothing blue jays
oh what a pick by urshela
took a hit away from smith
two away
that's why they called the hot corner
coming in high
michelle made that look easy
on the shortening him getting some games
under his belt all of a sudden you know
he's knocking the rust off he's getting
back to where you know he looks
comfortable defensively
i don't think they're going to start the
runner here
sanchez is not running and there's a
ground ball maria's goes to second right
on the money to mow whoa what a nice
throw by the pitcher
do that you're going to win your share
of games
there's a fly by the left field hit hard
guri out back makes a nice running catch
he was shaded in that direction
but he was shallow he had to turn and
burn and he runs it down to take a hit
away from gardner
there's anthony rizzo rizzo is over two
fouled out to third and then grounded
softly to second
drill deep to right field there it goes
see ya tie game
a two-run home run to tie the game
rizzo rakes into the right field seats
nobody beats the rizz
it's a two-run blast and the yankees tie
the game at two
and there was no doubt about that
hernandez never moved
never moved he just watched it as it
flew over his head
more hits including a leadoff home run
in the first he's got another multi-hit
game
well goes after the first pitch that's
going to get down for a base hitting
chance is going to come in to score
there'll be no throw lamb goes to third
as bo comes through once again his third
hit of the ball game puts the blue jays
back out in front
and it brings beau bashette to the plate
he was hitless in the first three games
of this series
but he's had a good one tonight reaches
out on that slider guesses right on that
slider this is a big spot
nike offense has been sluggish at best
you talk about a modern pitching move
here i mean the days of the platoon
advantage kind of over right i mean
swing and a miss big out for peralta as
the blue jays leave the bases loaded but
they score one run
on two hits
and three men left
oscar hernandez walked to start it he
was caught trying to advance on the wild
pitch caught stealing
there's a ground ball off the
battlefield tourists to second and they
drop it
that is not going to be an out
because wade never had the ball
the pitch bridge swings and he lines a
base hit into left field rounding third
valera gets the stop sign the bases are
loaded with one out
full count one out
ball four he walked in a run danny
janssen
takes a bases loaded walk and you can
hear the yankee fans reacting as they
force home another run
yeah you got plenty of fastball now you
got to figure out where you want to
throw the fastball here again they've
had
some success going up and up and into
them
just don't want him to extend and get
those long arms on the ball
ground ball to third second for one back
the first double play
what a pitch by tim mazur
here's vlady
vladimir guerrero jr
3-2 guerrero swings and he skies one out
to deep right field judge back at the
wall he turns around it's gone
an opposite field moon shot
from vladimir guerrero jr
his 42nd home run of the season
rbi number 100 for vladimir guerrero jr
he's the first blue jay since 2016
to hit over 40 home runs and drive in
100 or more before he's bounced right
back here in september
2-2 pitch to valera he gets a base hit
in the alley
the oscars around second headed for
third wade's throw back into the infield
he's getting the green light here's the
throw to the plate
and sanchez drops the ball
so hernandez will score as breivik
valera ends up at third base on the
throw another big run for the blue jays
here in the ninth
driven deep to left fair ball it's gone
it is off the screen
a home run
gary sanchez and the blue jays lead
6-3 chris sanchez his 21st home run
his 50th rbi and the yankees trail 6-3
so you know see the difference if people
went the other way and got on
pearson
will deal 2-2
swung on it driven to left it is high it
is far it is god
another solo blast
[Applause]
voigt hits one to detroit
[Applause]
oh that void is a troity it's a pinch at
home run
and the yankees now trail 6-4
yankees have now hit three home runs in
this game
called strike three and that's the ball
game nate pearson bounces back and
strikes out her sheller to end it and
for the first time in a long time the
blue jays win a four-game series sweep
the yankees